I am very curious how much time passes
in the John Wick Universe between the
beginning of the first John Wick movie
to the end of John Wick 4. good question
I'm gonna go so well we figure the first
three movies almost happened in like a
week week and a half somewhere in there
that's that's my version I think Kiana's
a little different and I think this is
like six months later so within a year I
think it all happens I would say almost
within seven eight months so for people
that don't really so the first three you
said it was a week and a half it's
almost like a week and a half time wise
right did you ever think about putting
on screen like time you know what I mean
like we did we actually did I think it
was in the saying we actually kind of
thought about that between the two but
like ah that's kind of goofy we'll just
let people guess because we didn't know
how bad we were going to injure them so
you know after number three you're like
okay we can stretch it a little bit but
he did fall off a building so like yeah
femur six months in this particular
interview I want to focus on one thing
which is uh the Berlin action which has
tons of extras behind Keanu for people
that might not realize there's a reason
in movies you do not see a ton of extras
between behind hard to coordinate behind
your a you're you're a star because of
the challenges so can you sort of
explain to people the the this sequence
and why it was so I mean why it's such a
hard thing to pull off okay so when you
have a lot of people so that's a lot
that's like wrangling kittens and and
when you deal with continuity
um not only are they just maybe if it's
just behind them and they're two people
sitting drinking coffee it's an easy
repeatable motion if I'm over you and I
see them when you're in a dance club and
now you have a specific song you have a
beat and at the same time I don't know
why I did it but we have flashing lights
so when you edit you're trying to find
the rhythm of the lines so that we have
a light coordinator that's trying to
keep the Reds yellows blue screens of
the club match to the same guy that's
doing the musical playback so the beat
is landing at the same time so you don't
get 300 people and then another 300
people on the wrong beat and then on top
of that you have people that'll look at
the camera or not be in the right spot
or something you know there's just it's
a whole nother layer of things that can
go wrong when you're trying to nail
these fight beat moments and then we
thought oh let's put a dog in there and
do fight scenes too like and let's put
44 waterfalls in yeah that'll be fine it
will figure it it's not it takes a lot
the resets were probably about
um like a reset will be we'll yell we'll
go we'll do the action and then
something will have wheel cut the water
comes off the Music Stops everybody's
got to go back they back up and like so
every time you do another take and you
reset it's a good 10 minutes to get the
Rhythm in and fix the problem and go so
now you're stopping 100 times a night
that's a lot of time
um but we were a little bit smarter this
time because I went out and got these 20
I got a dance troop some of the best
modern like kind of hip-hop or or
extreme Club dancers from brilliant we
put this little troop together these
like 20 people and we kept I'm like I
forget what it was but it was literally
over two dozen wardrobe changes for each
of them between the men and the women
and we kept using the same 15 to 20
people in and around Keanu every chance
I could get so at least they got the
Rhythm right and we had to keep changing
their hair and then you find out by the
third night what were the the background
players that are kind of paying
attention to get it right and you kind
of take that 100 and keep that close to
the shot and the other hundred go well
into the background so you know they're
you're kind of getting right but it was
challenging
um
but having the dancers go off was was
pretty cool so that was I think the
other day was worth it oh maybe not I
don't know oh no uh it was um we will
continue more later this afternoon uh
that sequence is crazy we never
get a chance I love music and to try and
work music in some I think that's how we
got the club we wanted to know the club
scene but in a different way and tying
water to it on stuff but then that idea
kind of grew to be the DJ like how do
you get needle drops how do you get all
these great musical pieces into John
Wick which is typically very you know
specifically uh composed so you know we
went from the club going out we like
music that was really fun like ah we
gotta do something with DJ we'll have a
DJ do needle drop that's it and that's
how we came around to the Walter Hill
thing of of the Warriors and stuff crazy